we are now going to talk about what is
perhaps the most important macro
molecule in life and that is known as
nucleic acid now first of all where does
that name come from well scientists
first observed this in the nucleus of
cells and so that's where you get the
nucleic part and it has some acidic
properties and so that's where you get
the acid part and perhaps the most
famous of the nucleic acids is deoxyribo
acid or dna for short and we'll go into
some depth in this as we go through our
journey in biology but you might already
know that this is the molecule that
stores our hereditary information this
dna to a large degree makes you
you and it's known as a macromolecule
and we've talked about macromolecules in
other videos we've talked about
carbohydrates and we have talked about
proteins and dna is a macromolecule
because it can be made of many millions
of atoms just to get a sense of it you
can see right over here the double helix
of dna where you have one
one side of your helix right over there
and then another one right over here and
then you kind of have these rungs of
this twisted ladder
a dna molecule let's say in the human
genome a chromosome for example is
primarily a really long dna molecule and
it can have on the order of a hundred
million rungs to this ladder
now another thing to appreciate like
many other macromolecules dna or nucleic
acids in general they are polymers in
that they are made up of building block
molecules and those building blocks for
nucleic acids and dna is the most famous
nucleic acid and rna ribonucleic acid
would be a close second but the building
blocks of them are known as nucleotides
nucleotides and we see some examples of
nucleotides right over here this is
d-oxy adenosine monophosphate which
would be a nucleotide found in dna you
can see the various parts of it you have
a phosphate group right over here you
have a five carbon sugar which in this
case is ribose and then you have what is
known as a nitrogenous base and why is
it called nitrogenous well those blue
circles represent nitrogen and we've
seen this before the grays are carbons
and the reds are oxygens and the whites
are hydrogens and so this part of the
molecule has some basic characteristics
while this phosphate group at the end
this has some acidic characteristics and
what happens is they get stacked onto
each other where the ribose phosphates
alternate to form the backbone of this
dna molecule you can see it right over
here where you have a phosphate and a
ribose and a phosphate and a ribose and
then you have the nitrogenous base
forming part of the rung of the latter
and the way that dna stores information
is every one of these nitrogenous bases
right over here this is adenine it has a
complementary nitrogenous base on the
other
to complete that rung of the ladder so
adenine matches with thymine and dna and
we'll see in future videos in rna it's a
nitrogenous base known as uracil and
guanine matches with cytosine don't
worry too much about this now we'll go
into some depth in this in future videos
when we talk about dna and how
information is stored in it but for the
sake of this video just appreciate that
the monomer for a nucleic acid like dna
is a nucleotide so monomer
and to be very clear this would not be
the only monomer the analogous
nucleotide in rna which stands for
ribonucleic acid would be adenosine
monophosphate right over here you can
see the difference between the two that
we have an oxygen right over here and we
don't have an oxygen right over here
that's why this is called deoxy and
that's why it's
deoxyribonucleic acid you're missing one
of those oxygens on your five carbon
sugar but adenine as i mentioned is not
the only nitrogenous base
you could have a nucleotide where the
nitrogenous base is thymine and so once
again this looks very similar but notice
what is going on over here
you could have a nucleotide that looks
like this once again you have your five
carbon sugar here you have your
phosphate group but the nitrogenous base
year keeps on changing and it's the
order of these different nucleotides
that actually encodes the information in
dna
now one question you might say is well
look if i have this part of the molecule
that has basic characteristics why is it
considered an acid well look at how this
molecule is structured the basic parts
form the rungs of this ladder so they're
not going to be as reactive because
they're really tight they're closer to
the inside of the molecule while the
acidic parts the phosphate groups are on
the outside so they're going to be more
reactive and so the molecule as a whole
is going to have an acidic
characteristic
i'm going to leave you there in future
videos we're going to go into a lot more
depth in the importance of nucleic acids
especially dna and rna and to just to
appreciate how amazing these molecules
are some folks theorize that the first
signs of life were nothing more than
self-replicating rna molecules that
eventually got it enclosed in cell in
some type of membrane structures which
eventually started forming the genetic
machinery of a cell etc etc etc so this
is why these nucleic acids are sometimes
considered the most fundamental
macromolecule to life